i can't help myself i like good food
okay and
good food is hard for a rat to find
thanks to tick-tock ratatouille has
officially reached
new heights as the beloved cultural
phenomenon it always deserves to be
but why is that and why now sure the
animation is amazing
how did you do that the story is
heartwarming the characters are lovable
and the food looks delicious but why did
the message of ratatouille hit so hard
at this exact moment
in time keep watching to find out anyone
can cook well yeah anyone can
that doesn't mean that anyone should
all the way back in 2007 when we first
heard that pixar was making
a movie about a rat cooking food in a
restaurant kitchen we thought
gross i saw it having a rat anywhere
near food just seems like
a bad idea and to make a whole animated
movie about it
it'll never work and yet just like ego
the snooty food critic with his old
school beliefs about what defines a real
chef
by the end of the movie we were totally
won over
let rats cook all of the meals okay
so maybe not in real life but in this
case the story of remy and his human
friend linguini
who arise from the bottom to be declared
the finest chefs in all of france
is without a doubt one of the best pixar
stories of all time
so i'm not crazy sure it might not have
been as big of a sensation as toy story
as action-packed as the incredibles or
have as many iconic lines as monsters
inc
may the best monster win but we think
that ratatouille stands out from the
rest of the pixar lineup
for so many reasons to start with it has
all of the story elements that make up
an awesome pixar movie
a hero who we meet while he's
questioning the life he feels
inescapably trapped in
before he falls down to his lowest point
in this case literally in the sewer
and then we get to go along for the ride
as he climbs to his eventual triumph
over all
obstacles it has gorgeous animation a
beautiful score
some great jokes and a cast of equally
lovable supporting characters
but on top of all of that we get the
ending and the ending is what makes
ratatouille one of the best films that
pixar has ever made
because it's not just about a rat who
wants to be a chef
it's about what it really means to be an
artist to have an unshakable need to
create something beautiful
even when the world tries to stop you in
every possible way
you with me it's about class and the
barricades that have been put in place
to make sure that only a select few are
able to rise to the top
even the meal that remy cooks to finally
win over the formidable ego
ratatouille means so much more than it
might seem
it's a vegetable stew that was
originally made by poor farmers in the
southern part of france
and by making it for ego remy
immediately transports him back to his
own humble beginnings
and reminds him that good food means so
much more than how
fancy it is how difficult it was to
prepare or where the chef learned to
cook
sure almost all pixar movies have their
own heartwarming message at the end
but as we live through a time that is
challenged so much more about the world
we inhabit
it's no accident that this movie has
recently hit home with millions of
people
and why ratatouille has found its new
home on tick tock
we have to wonder would ratatouille have
had such a massive comeback if we
weren't currently in the middle of a
global pandemic
what's more important here some of us
stuck at home with not a whole lot to do
to keep busy
and would any of it have happened
without tick tock
see way back in august we were all still
figuring out what to do with the huge
amount of free time on our hands
in a world that had changed
significantly many turn to tick tock as
a way to entertain themselves
including one user named emily jacobson
who innocently uploaded a little clip of
herself singing a song about remy the
rat
with no idea what kind of storm she had
just set in motion
the quick video went viral which is when
composer daniel mertzlaft
got involved and really turned things up
a notch
he transformed the simple tune into a
triumphant orchestral finale
in which he envisioned glitter and
confetti reigning onto the audience as
40
ensemble singers triumphantly belted the
tune to their beloved remy
standing center stage it didn't take
long for the ball to continue to roll
as songs like ratatouille tango there's
good in the garbage
and anyone can cook appeared on the
platform rounding out the show and
giving a voice to all of the different
characters
and then it wasn't just singers and
composers who were getting involved
all of the choreographers set designers
costume designers stage managers and
lighting designers who might have been
too busy to participate in previous
years
hopped on to the ratatouille train and
brought the show's visuals to life
and just like that out of nowhere
thousands of creators with no theaters
to work in and millions of spectators
no shows to go and see were actually
creating a full-scale broadway musical
together
from scratch while sitting in their
living rooms alone
this wasn't just a funny meme anymore
ratatouille the musical became an
outlet for creators and audiences to
come together once again
after months of feeling isolated alone
and
completely cut off from what once gave
them so much joy
thanks for coming back little chef and
just like the ending of ratatouille
the movie they tore down the barriers
that normally stand between artists
and their ability to work there were no
auditions no casting directors no
gatekeepers deciding who would be
allowed in or not
because of what school they went to or
how long their resume was just like remy
and his cooking
this was all about the love of making
something wonderful for
everyone to enjoy ratatouille the
musical was more about the community
making it than the actual thing itself
and that is something that is pretty
rare these days
while it is possible that ratatouille
the movie might have found a new
audience all these years later on its
own
and without a global pandemic to kick
things off we're not so sure that
ratatouille the musical would have
and we don't think it's a coincidence
that this movie with its message that
art can come from anyone
no matter who or where they are
resonated so clearly with all of us
right now for millions the pandemic has
made us feel as though our entire lives
have been taken away from us
as though we had lost all of the things
that had once made us feel happy and
busy and fulfilled
whether you were a musician or an actor
with no stage to play on or an audience
member who could no longer get so much
joy out of going to see a show with your
friends and family
we all found ourselves feeling a little
bit lost
but coming together over tick-tock to
bond over the story of a little rat
named remy
really helped so many people feel a tiny
bit more
found
and of course everything we love about
ratatouille always brings us back to the
ending
when the movie came out in 2007 the
world was a very different place
and sure we thought that the message of
the movie was sweet but
it didn't really resonate in the same
way it does now let's take a quick look
at where the four most important
characters started off at the beginning
of the movie
we first meet remy when he and his
family are forced to hide in the walls
of a human's home
constantly fearing for their lives and
scrounging for food in order to survive
his family considers his dream of being
an artist frivolous because for them
mere survival is their only goal first
of all we
are not thieves secondly stay out of the
kitchen
linguine is a young man who has achieved
a position as a chef in a very important
restaurant
even though he doesn't really have all
that many skills has no trading and
is seriously clumsy we find out later
that his success
hasn't been earned but has been awarded
to him just because he's the son of the
great
august cousteau and heir to his legacy
join us we then have colette the only
woman working in the kitchen
who has had to work much harder than any
of her colleagues simply because she is
who she is
and who is understandably hesitant to
help linguini who has had everything she
dreams of
simply handed to him you are the boss
inspire him and finally we have ego the
man who has been declared the only voice
in deciding what is good
and what is bad and delights and
striking fear into the hearts of chefs
all over paris
he has long since upheld the old world
ways of french cuisine that
only favor those who are exactly like
the men who came before
with open disdain for anyone or anything
that is considered
different i don't like food
i love it until he tastes
remy's ratatouille that is as soon as
the so-called peasant food hits ego's
taste buds
he is immediately reminded that he too
was once on the outside
dreaming of a world that seemed like it
would never welcome him
he is brought back to what good food
really means
family love and acceptance and when he
is finally introduced to the real chef
behind his transformative meal
all of the rules and guidelines that he
has spent years enforcing about who is
allowed to cook
good food go right out the window he
admits that the food he ate
and more so the chef who cooked it
challenged his idea of what
fine cooking really is and as he said
rocked him to his core ego who once
openly mocked the great chef gusto's
motto
anyone can cook now understands that
that is actually
completely true but i realize only now
do i truly
understand what he meant but it doesn't
actually matter what you look like where
you come from or what kind of access you
were born into
for the first time he realized the most
fundamental part of that message
not everyone can become a great artist
but a great artist can come from
anywhere the ending of ratatouille makes
us wonder
just how much of what we believe to be
good or bad are
outdated rules that were taught to us
when we were younger
it asks us to question the way we judge
other people because of where they come
from
or what they look like or how much money
they have because
when it comes down to it none of these
things actually matter in the end
everyone deserves a fair chance to be
who they want to be and
create the things they want to create
even if they are just a tiny little rat
named remy with a dream of making
delicious food
and that dear friends is exactly why the
ending of ratatouille is the
best thing to happen to pixar we're not
crying or you're crying
well we all thought that we'd need tons
of amazon packages and elaborate
skincare routines to get us through the
pandemic
it turns out all we really needed was a
little ratatouille
what about you were you just as
enchanted as we were by this pixar
classic
or do you have another animated favorite
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
keep up with all the latest videos from
the things